lobby of Ramsey solutions Jake and
Melinda are with us hey guys how are you
hey welcome where you guys from
we are from Union Kentucky just about 20
minutes south of Cincinnati oh okay very
cool very cool I think these are
Kentucky high school students hanging
around with us today I believe they are
so this is Kentucky day apparently all
right very cool so you're here to do
your debt-free scream how much have you
paid off we've paid off one hundred and
eighty thousand dollars Wow
and most that was all mortgage debt we
were actually on track to pay it off
this fall and my parents gave us a nice
unexpected gift and we knew exactly what
we were gonna do with it so we threw it
all in the mortgage and got it finished
it all yeah
I love it so how long did it take over
all the do that eight and a half years
eight and a half years Wow very cool
okay and what's your range of your
income during that time household we
started out around 130 K combined income
but three years into the payout in 2010
we decided to have a family and I was
part of living like no one else so we
had the option that she can stay home
with our boys right and and then we
continued to pay it out and our income
dropped sure about sixty at that point
okay which was pretty difficult mom
comes home yeah that's right and then
over the years last five six years it's
our income and steadily climbed back up
to an average around 108 she started a
handbag business on handbags in 2011
mm-hmm and we we crept back ups about
108 so who so you're selling those
handbags over the internet or how
internet doing home parties and things
like that okay
all right is it a group or something you
started no it's actually like a direct
sales oh okay cool very cool and that's
got some income coming in yeah so what
puts you guys on this path eight and a
half years ago that you said unlike most
people I think I'm going to pay off our
mortgage what was that well for me it
goes way back I mean maybe when I was a
young teenager a little younger than
these kids in here today you know watch
some family members struggle with that
you know credit cards you know robbing
Peter to pay Paul
you know just oh just a struggle the
stress and I saw that at a young age and
I was like you know I just can't can
imagine living that way and doesn't
doesn't look very fun so so I decided to
made that made the decision that you
know I don't care how much money I was
going to make I'm not gonna live like
that mm-hmm and I and I'm and I
continued to live you know within my
means and so I am unlike a lot of a lot
of your people that call in I'm always
been pretty weird you know you say we
just typically the nerd in the free
spirit we're really a couple of nerds
okay so what caused you to actually sit
down and start a systematic plan okay
well when we got married we didn't know
about you obviously were debt-free
consumer debt free we got married in
2003 and then we learned about you I've
got some friends that introduced us to
you and then at that point we really for
the first time I did a budget and and we
really we buckled down and and and like
let's let's save for home and put down a
big down payment and okay and in 2007 we
show you were listening on the radio or
you read one of the books or so yeah
yeah yeah listen on the radio that's how
we started out of course we got your
books and we've also taught your FPU
over here thank you yeah thank you so
you're not only went through it you
taught it okay so that whole set of
information became ingrained into you
okay I got you
yeah very cool first learned about
yellows like oh man this guy actually
thinks like I do he doesn't like loans
on car debt or Lisa desert or anything
like that so finally found another crazy
guy yeah you guys are officially weird
how old are you I am 37 I'm 39 and your
house is paid for what's this house
worth it's a bit worth about what we
paid for it which is around 255 Wow well
that's a good lesson because these teens
that are standing here around you
they've gone through our high school
curriculum yeah the Foundation's in
personal finance so there you stand is
like real people who have really paid
off their house and they're not even 40
they have their house paid for and then
you can run the math of what that house
payment alone will be worth five six
million dollars if you invested between
now and the time you retire just that
house payment will be worth that so you
guys are absolutely incredible way to go
guys Thanks
when people find out you paid off your
house and they say how'd you do that
what do you tell people or when you're
doing coordinating a class and they say
how did you really do that what's the
real deal what do you really do to get
out of that what do you tell them the
main thing you have to know to get out
of that is well you just have to be
consistent for one thing and have a
budget and one of the biggest things
that helped us is just doing the
envelope system like okay here's how
much money we're going to spend on
groceries this is what we're going to
spend on eating out and of course you
know there's been plenty of times they
had to tell friends like no we can't go
out we already spent all our eating out
money which was you know it's not always
easy but you know it's paid off very
cool for me for me it's a staying out of
stores and staying away from car
dealerships you got a car thing huh me
too brother
yeah I mean you show up a store or
suddenly you see things that you need
you know if you stay out of those stores
you're not going to need these things
you'll do with what you got they're
really good at selling stone yeah they
learn if you stay away from them you
don't have that problem that's right
well congratulations you guys again this
is really important what was the hardest
part of this eight and a half year
journey yeah I think for me it's just
just holding back not being able to spin
and do the things that that we want to
do watching everybody else you know go
to football games baseball games Muse
Matt parks you know and we held back on
a lot of that a lot of the entertainment
sector of our life has been kind of dull
you know I mean but that's what we did
to sacrifice it was worth it to us and
you got the rest of your life do
anything I want that's right exactly
live like no one else later you get to
live and give like no one else yep way
to go you guys all right and your are
your kids with you they are and what are
their names and ages Desmond is almost 6
and Emmet is almost for this model oh
very cool sharp lookin young guys now is
this mom and dad with you it's my
parents all right yeah I guess mom and
dad are pretty proud yeah I bet very
cool all right well we got the whole
gang here to do a debt-free scream
Desmond and Emmet Jake and Melinda from
Lexington Kentucky $180,000 paid off
that's their house and everything
they're weird eight and a half years it
took them making 130 down to 60 back to
108 count it down let's hear a debt-free
scream all right three
- one word
I love it I
very very well done man that's how it's
supposed to be right there
well thank you for joining us very cool
you guys you're heroes that's absolutely
incredible hey you guys Rachael Cruz
here hope you're enjoying the Dave
Ramsey show and did you know that I have
my very own YouTube channel yes that's
right it's kind of better than the same
room the channel don't tell them I said
that I'm kidding I'm kidding
so subscribe and there's lots of videos
about life and money so while you're at
it if you want to check out a video then
you can check out how to do a monthly
budget it's one of the best videos out
there
you